welcome back to this special edition of
hannity we've been telling you for a
long time that on this show that the
border crisis is out of control and now
finally dhs secretary alessandro
mayorkas seems to agree here's what he
said to the border patrol in leaked
audio obtained by us fox news listen
what is the first line of defense uh
we're gonna lose and this is
unsustainable uh we can't continue like
this uh our people in the field can't
continue and our system isn't built for
it
a rare moment of honesty but don't
expect the mainstream media to make a
big deal out of this story or the
record-breaking number of migrant
encounters in july according to
newsbusters the network ignored that
story but were eager to cover britney
spears conservatorship battle joining me
now with reaction are fox news
contributor joe concha tom homan and
sarah carter uh joe let me just go to
you right now uh i've been i mean sure
i'll go i'll go to tom let me go to tom
first tom let me go to you right now uh
i find the leaked audio from the dhs
secretary at admission of failure how do
you see it
well look i've been saying for seven
months the secretary's lying to the
american people he's on national tv
claiming the board is close and secure
he's testified in front of congress at
least three times saying the board is
secure and it's closed
and you he cannot go down to the
southern border look the men and women
wearing green and tell them that because
he probably wouldn't make it out of
there because they're dealing with this
every day so i'm certainly i'm convinced
he didn't know he's being taped or he
would never have said that but look this
border is not secure
it's not closed we got over a million
apprehensions by this administration
under this president we have two hundred
thousand people release
manny mccovid we have fentanyl coming
across the border record numbers with 92
000 overdose deaths trafficking is up we
have 20 over 20 border places died at
covid that come across that border he
took the most secure border i've seen in
my entire career and made it the most
out of control border i've he has this
the border is disaster on the short time
he's been president i don't see anything
like it's the worst border situation
i've seen in my career
you know uh sarah this situation you
know britney spears situation is a
smoking screen type of scenario because
the left-wing media wants to focus on
britney spears but they don't want to
focus on what is affecting everyone in
this country the the illegal migration
of illegal aliens on one hand they talk
about masking up and they're having
thousands of these people
across the border with covet how do they
get away with it
a leo you're right i mean look i was
just there i just returned today from
mcallen texas i can tell you this the
residents in mcallen the residents all
across the border towns their resources
are strained they're frustr they're
frustrated they see a rise in covid uh
tom homan's right we have now 400 border
patrol agents who are at home with
coveted related illness
and you know have to stay off duty for
at least two weeks others who have
passed away they're on the front lines
and let's talk about the humanitarian
crisis
if you really care if if
president biden says he truly cares
about the people that are coming in here
then he'll stop this because those
people that are coming across the border
are being trafficked by human
traffickers drug cartels uh they're
being exploited they are dying
themselves and obtaining covid so what
we're seeing is a devastating situation
on the border and i can tell you this a
lot of dhs officials that i've spoken to
a lot of federal law enforcement and
local law enforcement are saying flat
out that president biden is derelict in
his duties you know i agree with that no
disagreement there at all joe i know
you're joe i know you're a big britney
spears fan but we got to focus on the
border i'm asking you seriously from a
standpoint of how the media
can basically be in bed with joe biden
focus on everything else but
the crisis at the border and get away
with it i mean what inside poll numbers
is he looking at you're a media guru how
is he getting away with it for such a
long time
well we weren't supposed to share the
whole britney spears thing my first
workout song every day is toxic i admit
it but it is a toxic situation at the
border uh leo as i transition out of
that awkward uh transition so look axios
is now reporting that 50 000 migrants
were released into the u.s without a
court date and president biden has been
in office for more than 200 days he has
yet to visit the border which is in
crisis and perhaps that's why it's been
more than 90 days since he's done a
one-on-one interview and that's
different from oppressor a leo because
halfway a halfway decent journalist who
cares about accountability there are a
few out there believe me
would press the president when he gives
a vague generic bs answer impress him in
the case of the border one would only
have to hammer home the numbers that you
just talked about or read back the
quotes from democratic lawmakers and
mayors in border states and towns saying
this is humanitarian crisis show him
photos of facilities at three four five
hundred percent over capacity and asked
sir what is your plan and how could you
say that your vice president is doing a
good job because again mr biden put vice
president harris in charge of solving
this crisis at the border which is a
fascinating choice when you consider
that harris agreed that all legal
boarding crossings should be made legal
and compared ice to the kkk and harris
has yet to hold one press conference on
this and her role began what 140 days
ago so you would think after secretary
mayarka's visit this week and his dire
comments that were caught on tape that
nbc cbs abc and their evening newscast
that are watched by 20 million people
combined would have covered it but they
barely touched it because britney spears
to your point took major president i'm
not saying that britney isn't a story
but there's no reason that you can't do
both by the way leo i want to debut this
uh this is an idea i have i'm thinking
about it
and it's completely original right
i got
you been had he's gotten me hey
thank you joe
thank you tom thank you sarah
hey no and joe i'm blushing joe can you
tell i'm blushy right now thank you
everybody appreciate it joe tom and
sarah thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else